El costo de ponerle gasolina al coche, costo,
es directamente proporcional a la cantidad de litros...
la cantidad de litros de gasolina que le pones.
Déjame escribir esto aquí abajo con algunas letras...
Vamos a ponerle "x" a la cantidad de litros comprados...
al número de litros...
litros...
comprados,
los que le ponemos al coche...
comprados...
y vamos a ponerle "y"...
"y" al costo...
al costo...
De lo que gastamos en esa puesta de gasolina
¿vale?
Entonces nos dicen que el costo
es directamente proporcional
a la cantidad de litros comprados,
es decir, que podemos escribir a "y",
como una cierta constante,
multiplicada por "x",
eso es que "y" sea directamente proporcional a "x".
Bueno, vamos a seguir,
además nos dicen,
si un litro de gasolina cuesta 12.50,
¿cuántos litros puedes poner con 100 pesos?
Bueno, pues vamos a ver,
qué información nos da esto de aquí,
dice 1 litro de gasolina cuesta 12.50,
es decir, tenemos que si "x" es igual a 1...
si "x" es igual a 1,
entonces "y" es igual a 12.50
Entonces con esta información,
podemos obtener el valor de "k", como sigue,
simplemente sustituimos,
obtenemos que 12.50...
12.50 es igual a "k" por "x",
a "k" por 1,
pero "k" por 1 es simplemente "k",
entonces esto lo puedo tachar
y aquí nos queda que "k" es igual a 12.50
"k" es igual a 12.50
Muy bien entonces con este valor de "k",
ya podemos saber el costo en términos de "x",
nos quedaría que "y",
"y" es igual a 12.50 por "x"
Y ahora lo que nos preguntan es,
¿cuántos litros puedes poner con 100 pesos ?
Es decir nos están dando el valor de "y"
y con eso queremos determinar el valor de "x",
de los litros-
Déjame hacer esta operación por acá...
voy a agarrar este color rosa...
entonces sabemos que "y" es igual a 100...
"y" es igual a 100
y eso tiene que ser igual a "12.5x"
¿cómo le hacemos para obtener "x"?
pues dividimos a ambos lados de la igualdad entre 12.5
hacemos 100 entre 12.50
y vamos a hacer esta operación a ver cuánto nos queda, nos quedaría que "x" es igual a...
vamos a hacer la división,
a ver 12.50,
12.50
es lo mismo que,
12 más un medio
y 12 más un medio,
es lo mismo que 24 más 1, o sea 25 medios,
entonces si hacemos 100 entre 12.50,
eso es lo mismo que hacer 100 por 2...
100 por 2,
porque estamos dividiendo entre 25 medios,
y esto dividirlo entre 25...
25...
100 entre 25 es igual a 4
y 4 por 2 es igual a 8
y de esta forma la cantidad de litros
que podemos poner con 100 pesos es 8,
"x" es igual a 8 litros.
Muy bien.